philanthropy to me is uh is a class
distinction it has a an aura that means
it is something that the wealthy do and
most of the time when you look at the
way in which philanthropy is
administered I often look at it as
somebody buying their right to a greater
humanity than they in fact lived and
somehow philanthropy was the way in
which those who crushed humanity failed
of that fact by just giving to those
whom they crushed giving to those whom
they abused and for me the idea
philanthropy always carried with it a
great suspicion as to what motivates
this philanthropy once you get past that
initial of question I then began to
understand the importance of having to
encourage philanthropy to invest itself
in the issues of justice so that it
became more productive for me to seduce
philanthropy to the causes that I felt
committed to change than just to ignore
philanthropy cheated as a class issue
and move on elsewhere it made no sense
and in that context I began to develop
friendships and relationships awesome
fairly powerful people and institutions
and showed a great deal of philanthropy
or responded with a great deal of
philanthropy and a lot of them we
wouldn't have achieved many of the
things we did had not been for their
intervention so despite the ambulance
despite the conflicts beside try not
wrestle with the definition I soon got
over that because there's a lot of
complicated things to the system of life
that we have found ourselves at both
economically and politically and life is
a constant sorting out of how to make
this thing work